foreign
what's up Tessa how we doing
hey John how's it going I mean literally
could not be better how are you
excellent first off
that's the nicest thing I think anyone's
ever said to me and my wife even said I
do and this what you just said I think
was nice man it's true
things I never thought I could well you
Hey listen I run my mouth on a podcast
in on a YouTube you actually are out
there doing it so thank you you're the
hero here man it's awesome so what's up
Sean
so as you would say I think I found
myself in a situation not by my hand
or yeah not by him but in my lap oh no
what happened
um my kids recently have been playing
with the neighbor boy which we've lived
in this house for seven years and I have
a seven and a five-year-old
and they've just started noticing the
neighborhood across the street who moved
in about six months after us so
basically the whole time I've been here
okay
um he's nine
so as of like two weeks ago we thought
okay like they started noticing him they
could probably play together as long as
I felt comfortable as long as I could
see my kids and they were on my property
so we from five acre Parcels out kind of
in
the middle of nowhere okay that's where
that's where I'm at so you don't you
don't you don't have a relationship like
with the parents and whatnot
um up to this point it's all been a
negative relationship with the parents
they've called the cops on us because my
dog got holes are chickens after I had
reached out to them I mean it's kind of
I mean you got to call the cops that's
their chicken okay I'm just kidding so I
saw that that chicken so I could text
them I was like hey do you have chickens
I just found chicken like we'll make it
right no response the cops just got
called
and what's the lesson here Tessa just
eat the chicken jeez just don't message
your neighbor apparently that's no bueno
that's not good I'm sorry okay so yeah
um so you all aren't super tight but
then your daughters who are seven is
that right
yeah five and seven okay and you see
this handsome little neighbor boy this
is how Dawson's Creek starts by the way
and right so then you say it's cool but
they got to be on your place
yeah so our property opens up straight
to their house so like a very open field
we have a place that trampoline all like
the cool stuff you know so it's like
okay come over here you guys can play as
long as I can see you and if they're
riding their bikes they have walkie talk
to you so like we can communicate yeah
um and so
they start playing with this little boy
sold
I need your help John to figure out
where is the line on calling in the
troops versus just kind of keeping an
eye on the situation yeah so
um a couple days ago they were out
playing with him and
another little neighbor boy down the
street Drives By in his dad's truck
and
the neighbor across the street goes I
want to kill him
and my girls are like uh I'm not totally
sure the situation getting five and
seven relaying it to me
but then that same day within within
like a half hour time frame that little
boy now comes up to our house to play
and
the boy number one let's call him
so let's play The Who wants to kill your
mom game
and this call is taking a dra a turn I
was not I I thought you were gonna say
like your daughters thought this boy was
cute not that he was
like okay this is a really like serious
situation for sure yeah and like over
the weekend my daughter came to me so
like kind of a little a little more
history on this my daughter came to me
and said hey Mom I want to shoot a bird
or can we shoot Birds something like
that and I was like wait we don't just
shoot animals to kill animals we we
shoot to provide for our family but we
don't just shoot to kill and I was like
but if you want to shoot a gun of like
um we can talk we can shoot targets like
we have Targets in the backyard like a
safe area when dad comes home we can
totally go through targets I was like
but we don't shoot animals just to kill
an animal
so like
I'm learning that she got that from him
my dad was like well the neighbor boy
says he goes in his backyard and shoots
Birds yeah and then last summer
um we saw him riding his bike with a BB
gun in his hands and he actually shot a
dog on my property that was tied up just
hanging out yeah
so I'm like I'm like oh my gosh so now
all these like stars are lining and then
who wants to shoot your mom game fast
forward back to this other day
it's the two boys I guess and my girls
are there these boys are nine and ten so
older than my kids
and they said who wants to play the
shoot your mom game and they said raise
your hand if you want to shoot your mom
and then both boys raise their hand and
my son just goes mom we didn't raise our
hands
thank you I appreciate that yeah
um
yeah this is the situation I find myself
in is where do I go because
we live out in the middle of Idaho
we all have guns it's so it's just the
way it is
basically locked up sure I don't know if
my neighbor has a Shotgun by his front
door
that his kid could get to you know or
like
I don't know what happens in their house
all I know is what happens to mine right
and that's really all you can protect
right
right so so let's walk backwards here
okay and I think you've got a um a good
moment in time right now
um yeah are your kids in school
they are okay is this little boy go to
school
say that again does this little boy go
to school
yes they actually go to different
schools my kids are in a charter school
and he goes to the public school okay
so that might be your best friend right
now so in a normal situation and I I
actually think
um
I I think it's
if you have a great relationship with
your neighbor or a terrible relationship
with your neighbor
something like this is not going to hurt
it either way because it just is okay
right
and so
as a parent no matter how sideways
things get and I also understand rural
communities and there's just people that
live out on their land and don't want
nobody on their land and you know they
just do life very very differently okay
I get that I live out in the woods too
so
um
I do think and I just want to I just
wanna I think there's a Humane thing
which is I'm gonna tell Mom and Dad hey
your son's talking about guns shot a dog
on a property like talking about killing
your mom talking about shooting and
killing a neighbor boy like in the world
we live in now I just need to make y'all
aware of that and they may tell you to
go to hell you get off our property what
are you some kind of liberal free like
they can say all that stuff that's a
that's a that's how they get to choose
how they respond
they may abuse this little boy and beat
the tar out of him how dare you how
whatever or maybe maybe they say oh he's
he's picking up a lot more we need to
get these guns locked up
yeah probably not but maybe right and so
I think that's the place where we're
gonna start I would not when I say I
wouldn't let my kids play with him
that was one of my other questions too
yeah um and here's the thing I think
your seven-year-old and I think your
five-year-old are
old enough for you to say very basically
my job is to keep you safe and if boys
are talking about shooting people and
wanting to kill people then you will not
be playing with them
it's my job to keep you safe and so you
are making yourself the bad guy and you
are making yourself the the responsible
parent putting a boundary up okay and I
I would just hold to it and if he comes
over I would say hey we're we're not
gonna we're not playing right now thank
you so much
and he needs to go home
okay
you've made me a better mom
my kids when I told them
I basically asked them um what's my job
as a mom and they both said to keep us
safe healthy yeah
and then when we told them that we
weren't gonna be playing with them
anymore my seven-year-old Joe's mom it
doesn't it's not just sad for him it's
sad for us and my five-year-old goes
yeah it's really sad that he made that
choice I'll get you Mom of the Year
Tessa so I was honestly shocked when
they put the blame on him and not on us
they they understand that he's choosing
to not play with y'all because he's
talking about killing people
right now here's the I think I I
maybe I'm cynical at this point in my
life I I don't think the conversation
with mom and dad's gonna go great I just
don't
um
and it it may just not go great
but I think it's worth having it
nonetheless and even tell them we love
your kid we love your son it's all good
but in this day and age I just we just
need to say something
the second thing is
um and let me let me tell you this let
me back up a little bit so as a as a
school administrator which I was or as a
crisis responder here's what I'm always
looking for I'm always looking for
Trends particularly escalations or
de-escalations okay
so you got a kid who makes a a throwaway
statement I want to kill that kid well
that can be a rural hillbilly I'm gonna
kill that guy right that can be his mom
and dad yelling at the I'm gonna kill
that politician kind of stuff that could
just be rural speak
then who wants to play I want to kill my
mom game
and then I'm going around and there's
some language about violence escalation
to kids and it starts with herding
animals and it escalates from it
escalates in size two and I'm shooting
the neighbor's dog just not to not even
here's the thing not even to kill it or
not even to eat it it's just to watch it
hurt
right I'm shooting an animal just to
shoot it now we're getting into this
Psychopathology we're moving over into
like what I'm seeing is I'm feeling as
you're telling me this an escalation
here right and when you look back almost
every active shooter let me put a caveat
no no one's saying this kid's gonna be
an active cheater but when you look
backwards
the number of people who come out from
the woodwork could be like oh they told
me this or they texted me this or I knew
about this or they mentioned this or
they just bought that
every very very rare just something just
come out of the blue once people have
are able to look back and see all the
puzzle pieces that they weren't putting
together because they didn't know they
were having a puzzle okay so I think
there there's an escalation here that is
that demands your intervention so good
for you
I think your main intervention is going
to be with the school
and that was gonna be my question yes I
would call the school counselor and say
I'm the mother of a five-year-old and a
seven-year-old who go to x School our
neighbor plays they go to your school
um he's made multiple suggestions that
he's going to
kill a schoolmate kill a mom he shot
things with a BB gun on my property he's
talking to my kids about just shooting
animals
um in this day and age I just want to
make you guys aware
and they may not even be able to because
of uh FERPA federal education rights and
privacy they may not even be able to
confirm he's a student there cool that's
their deal but you'll know I let them
know and here's where that's a gift for
them
they may have a teacher who put in a
file this kid keeps talking about
shooting everybody
and they may have a PE teacher that had
to pull him aside and say so you're
you're adding a data point to an entire
picture that they have on this
particular young young man
or it may be the first time and then
they're going to reach out to the
teachers and say you guys have any
worries about this kid and they're gonna
be like oh yeah this gets crazy you
should read this poem he wrote or the
story he wrote and suddenly you're able
to head something off at the pass
okay
hear what I'm saying
yeah I actually so I
um I'm in the community right now like
I'm a board member on like a foster care
um
organization here and one of our board
members is a mental health specialist in
the school district and so I reached out
to her and she she also recommended
contacting CPS as well as the school
okay would you recommend CPS at this
point too
um
I mean I
such a touchy subject like that
yeah um here's what I'm I'm never gonna
do is well I say never sometimes there's
just idiots but
um I'm if you have a local mental health
practitioner that suggests that their
CPS
needs to be involved in this than I
would
okay
um or if you have any sense that you've
got parents that you're dealing with
that
um
don't care what their kids do and their
kids coming over your house at 11 30 p.m
or kids out there shooting stuff at 4am
right it's just there's the kid is
basically feral right he's got No
Boundaries no no adult intervention in
his life at all then yes because because
what we're with CPS what we're looking
at Child Protective Services is is there
neglect or is there abuse going on are
parents not doing their due diligence
with a child and letting the kid run
around and go I'll even say this in this
for those of you who live in Suburban
neighborhoods or who live in like in big
cities nine-year-old kids with a BB gun
out on a five acre
Farm is not weird it's just not weird
um and I know that sounds bizarre um but
it's just it's not weird
but shooting a dog on a neighbor's
property is is
like like to put that in perspective
I don't think like my son hunts with me
my son I mean I've tried to teach him at
a very very young age
um all the safety and all the stuff I
don't think it would even enter his mind
that would be like an alien invasion
that would never come into his brain to
shoot a dog right especially a
neighbor's dog especially just a like it
would never it's not it's not a normal
thought process is what I'm saying
okay so there's something not right
um if you're local if your local mental
health supervisor says you can call CPS
then call CPS
um if if I'm I would probably lean on
doing that after I talk to the parents
because you'll gauge their response
although and know this it's a
declaration of war for Neighbors
right you know you can call it cops on
my kids I mean then it's just a whole
other it's Hatfield and McCoys at that
point
um
yeah I actually already called the
non-emergency hotline okay
um and and they said well where you live
honestly all we deal with is
domestic violence and drunk driving yeah
that this because he didn't have a gun
in his hands when he said those words
that's right
there's no immediate threat rule America
gets the short in on a lot of sticks man
right yeah super under resourcing a lot
of mental health challenges and a lot of
addiction a lot of just innate um
generational struggles man
that uh there's not a lot of people
looking at the children saying hey if we
if we invest here if we get involved
here we can stop a whole lot of
Downstream challenges but
um
yeah I mean
I'm hesitant here's why I'm hesitant
because I just know that this this is
going to be tough on y'all
right and the chances of him being a
serial killer are are statistically very
very very low
but we're in a day and age where we have
to make that phone call now
yeah and we have to have that
conversation and
um
I hate that you're in that position
yeah
kind of taking over my whole week as you
can imagine yeah so let me give you some
wisdom there when these kind of things
spin up I would get out a note card or a
piece of paper and write down the four
or five phone calls you need to make and
put little tiny boxes next to them and
just start making those phone calls
because right now what you're gonna say
and who you're gonna call and it just
starts to take over your whole body
and you're watching the show and then
you're Googling who should I call and
you're like your husband's like wants to
hang out and party and you're like well
and you're scrolling like it just kind
of takes you it just pulls you away from
it you're from life
so yeah I'd put it on there just go out
the conversation across the street just
go ahead and talk to the school and
maybe the school will call CPS
and they can hold some of that
um
they can hold some of that
responsibility or at this point honestly
when I just I mean what goes on in my
community just recently I I don't care
about the blame anymore I just want kids
to be safe I'm just kind of tired of it
yeah it really sucks because I mean
I'm sure
he's a kid yeah that's right I would
love for him to like be able to just
hang out and play like I can't subject
my kids to it though and that's like the
thing I keep tossing back and forth my
head is kids are kids and I just want to
love them because they're kids
but I also can't put my kids in that
situation you have you have a
responsibility to your family and to
your kids to keep them safe and the
extension as by having kids one of the
things I say all the time is my kids are
your kids and your kids are my kids man
I need your kids to be safe too
and so because I'm a parent in the
community I
also have to make sure that I'm doing
what I can and my limited role I'm not
overzealous and I'm not trying to
control what I can't control but
I'm going to do my part to make sure the
other kids in the community are safe too
and at this point
when you've got a kid across the street
who has shown that he's just going to
recklessly shoot animals that he brags
about killing things just to kill them
when he talks about killing some a
classmate when he talks about killing
his mom and wanting to play a game about
killing his mom and he's trying to
recruit like
um
yeah it's just time to make some phone
calls
time to make some phone calls
the one thing I'll walk back and again
this um I'm thinking about all this in
real time
I I do have a
um
I do have a policy just a personal
policy that I only talk when I can be
heard I only speak when I can be heard
and if you get in a few seconds that
your neighbors have no interest in
talking to you get off our property you
scumbag we don't want to talk to you
whatever
um
then they're choosing to not engage with
you in a very difficult conversation
that needs to be had and I'll honor that
but I'm gonna go do what I need to do
and I'm gonna call the school and I'll
call CPS I'm gonna call my local mental
health authorities and I'm gonna make
sure this kid gets the help that he
needs
before he hurts himself or he hurts a
whole bunch of other people
you are Mom of the Year Tessa your mom
of the year
thank you so much for loving your kids
loving your community and loving that
little nine-year-old boy that's living
across the street
let me know how it goes I'm interested
to see how it plays out and I'll report
back to everybody these don't always
have a great ending and so uh thank you
so much for being brave